I guess you haven't been here in a while
retirement was the other Studio yeah oh
yeah that's a really long website about
you so much I feel like you've been here
that's what I thought yeah and you'll
talk about it
don't blow my comfort Joy wants to get
taken by you
and I will
I love it
so Liam Neeson slams The View saying he
was uncomfortable during a recent stop
by the daytime talk show that's true the
actor appeared on the ABC show last week
to promote his new flick Marlo
I'm not afraid to take you with me I do
like this thing about not being afraid
you should be but now Liam tells Rolling
Stone that the whole thing was a bit
embarrassing because the panelists kept
joking about Joy behar's long-standing
crush on him I got this Valentine from
you today
happy belated Valentine's Day Liam X and
then I and I was like oh and I find out
you gave it to all of us Liam tells the
mag that prior to his sit down he was in
the dressing room watching the ladies
talk about gun violence in America
during the break he says he went on
stage and praised them for having such
an important discussion it's not about
winning over people it's about telling
as much of the truth as we have but when
it was time for his segment things took
a turn it's no secret but joy thinks
you're oh the hottest and the greatest
ever
in case
in case there was any doubt we have a
few times she brought you up over the
years I think we have some videos I
would just like to have my ashes
sprinkled over Liam Neeson
Liam Neeson right now are those
kidnapping movies that he does get they
so aroused I can't even
just all this BS with joy and Liam
Neeson and having a crush and I've known
Whoopi for years and joy a little bit
but I just wasn't impressed I'm
uncomfortable in those situations you
know
[Applause]
[Laughter]
I'm speechless at this point Liam says
he had a good intelligent conversation
with Sonny Hosten after the show but his
segment oof 13 14 year old Crush it's
just a bit embarrassing listen I've been
on the air for 25 years they know what
to expect from me I'm me I'm me they
know Joy they have people know me
they expect the same thing again and
again and again yeah Joy's been
delivering her signature and apparently
sometimes cringy humor on the show since
it started in 1997. I say this show was
a volleyball game it's not a golf game
so if you know to hit the ball and then
wait for it to come back at you and all
that you'll be fine that's the only
advice I ever give anybody really
[Music]